- I feel like Mexican chips and flavors,
10 times better than
American chips and flavors.
- Smells like a fart a little bit.
(flamenco music)
(both laughing)
- [Both] Churrimais
- Con limoncito.
- Churima, so it's like
little churros with lime.
- (gasps) Oh.
- Sounds delicious.
- A lot of spices visible
on the chip, which I like.
- A lot of spices visible in my nose.
- The lime might be a little much.
I could do without the lime.
- Yeah, I mean, I feel that about
most lime chips.
- Agreed.
- Ooh!
- Whoa.
- Flavor sensation.
- That is a punch of lime.
- Actually, it's delicious.
- Muy bien.
- You know what it's
like, it's like a shrunken
voodoo head version of a churro.
- You're right, this is a churro for mice.
(man laughing)
- [Both] Gansito.
- It has a cute little,
uh, who's that guy again?
- Is that Howard the Duck?
- I love how alternative he is.
He's like, "I'm a cool duck.
"I'm a duck from the streets."
- This is like a Mexican Twinkie.
- Yes.
- I do like the weight
here, like this is a--
- It's a good snack.
- It's a hefty snack.
- Cheers.
- Boom.
- Oh, yeah!
- [Man] I love this.
- [Woman] I don't like it.
- Give me your half.
- I don't like it.
- I don't like the jam.
- I didn't like it the first
second I opened my mouth.
(man laughing)
- Sabritones. Did I get that right?
- This is gonna be (bleep)in' delicious.
That's a puffed chip that tastes like
chili and lime, let's eat it.
- Look at all the spices on this chip,
they are leavin' nothin' at home,
they're like goin' all out every time.
- Oh, fun, it's a party.
- When you first take a bite, it's like
"This is popcorn," and
then you get the spice.
And then, you get the lime.
- It's a three sensation experience.
- Cacahuates peanuts, Japones style.
- Why'd you say it like that? (laughs)
- You brought us to a Mexican taste test
and gave us Japanese peanuts?
That shit (bleep)ed up.
- Can I just tell you,
it smells like peanuts,
but it also smells like
grass in the summer.
- It smells like grass in the summer.
- (bleep) right, doesn't it
smell like grass in the summer?
- And what was the other thing you said?
- [Woman] Peanuts.
- [Man] Yeah!
(woman laughing)
Dead on.
- They're, like, in a thing.
- Yeah, they don't really--
- [Man] They look like rocks.
- [Woman] They don't look
like food, yeah, rocks.
- They look like cartoon food.
(crunching)
- Damn!
- [Man] This is delicious.
- [Woman] I'm into them.
- I don't know what it is.
- What is on you, nut?
- That's a great crunch,
I don't understand
what that crunch is.
- Yeah.
- They put something on
the outside of the peanut?
(loud crunching)
A ha, there's a crisp on this peanut.
- [Man] Rancheritos.
- [Woman] Yeah,
it's got a cowboy hat
and a bandana, ranch.
- Yee haw.
- This is Cool Ranch,
maybe, but the real ranch.
- Oh, it's just a Dorito.
(crunching)
It's the exact same thing.
- This is 100% Cool Ranch Dorito, like--
- These are Cool Ranch Doritos cut into
a different shape and
put in a different bag.
- Kinda barbecue-y.
- Yeah.
- But like, real barbecue, like
the, the smoke from the barbecue.
- Why do we have to have triangles?
Why can't we have strips?
- Strips seem a lot more efficient,
and I feel like, just at first glance,
a lot less crumbly in
there than a Dorito bag.
- I feel like Mexicans like spicy flavors
like chili and lime, and
Americans like mild-ass flavors
like cheese and sour cream.
(woman on left laughing)
Or like, the mildest
salsa that exists, right?
- Yes, like tomatoes.
- Yeah (laughs), they're like,
"No, no salsa, just, do you
have a paste of tomatoes?"
(woman on left laughing)